[Music]
okay good morning it's my pleasure to be
here thanks for having me and so today
I'll talk about a topic that I'm
actually very excited about which is
dealing with rate data in computer
vision I've worked on this if starting
from my PhD and I'm still continuing
with similar topic so why is it that I
like this problem well it turns out that
actually the world behaves like that
it's just for some reason it gives us
more data for some concepts are very
popular but for other concepts we have
only a few data or it's very hard to
collect data right so for example you
consider the Sun 397 data set so and
then plot the histogram of the instances
that you have in that data set you will
see that the the living room actually is
the concept that has the most instances
to actually work with but when you
actually find a skateboard park the
number of instances that you have
available is actually very you only have
a few instances to work with to give you
another instance of this problem feature
matching is another good example of this
so when you actually match features from
two images many of the candidate
correspondences that you get are
actually wrong so only a few portion of
them are actually good ok so so in
nature these true correspondences are
actually rare ok
and well we actually have to learn how
to deal with these rare events for
example consider self-driving car right
many of those systems for the perception
systems that they have very likely they
have or they're trained with the common
scenes or common events of the world
right but consider the case I don't know
that these self-driving car is actually
seeing these baby crawling on the street
it is a very unlikely event but actually
do happens actually when I was creating
this slide I found a few posts in the
news where actually this happened so if
we don't learn how to deal with these
rare events we can have horrible
outcomes right so I organized a talk as
follows so first I'm going to talk about
what I did essentially in my PhD dealing
with a correspondences and treat them as
rare
vents and then I will switch to current
topics that I'm actually working on
right now so the second one is learning
directly from a longtail data set and
then the third one is mainly just a
visualization framework for CNN's
dealing with pixel level tasks but it
has a relationship with rare events
especially I was interested in seeing
how CNN's behaved for input that the CNN
has never seen before and then I'll just
conclude ok so I'm gonna start with
correspondences any feature matching and
this work essentially aims to improve
ransac based algorithms to make them
faster but with a not with a novel
insight of treating these
correspondences through correspondences
as rare events and I'm gonna be using
statistics in order to model those rare
events in order to do so this was joint
work with other collaborators so here
Rodriguez Pradeep Singh and Matthew Turk
of course so image correspondence or
solving this image correspondence
problem is actually fundamental in
computer vision right so thanks to the
solution for that problem we can
actually reconstruct large 3d 3d models
we can actually localize cameras if we
have a 3d model for example or we can do
image image teaching and maybe many
other applications so it's an important
problem as I mentioned before solving
the image correspondence problem
typically throws us data that is not
useful I think so when you actually get
the candidate correspondences I will say
that actually 70% of them are actually
wrong and so if we're lucky 30% are
actually good okay and this is cause
because uh you know many things like
rotation illumination scale variations
and the poses of the camera so those
factors actually affect the feature
matter
so basically confuse it ok now so the
goal here or one of the first goals when
I started my PhD was can I actually
predict which of those kind of the
correspondences is is true or it's a
good one
based on the similarity scores that I
get when I run the feature match okay
and to give you the solution that I came
up with first let me review actually
that how is it that the feature matcher
works so imagine that I give you these
two images I want to reconstruct say for
example the Coliseum so the first step
that you do is that you detect your
features which are visualized with these
circles and then you basically forget
about the context of image where that
feature was located for now and then
what you do is that you only graph
patches surrounding that feature okay
then the next step is that you say for
example that I want to find the feature
matches for this query feature what you
will do is that you will compare their
representation say for example safe to
surf against all your reference features
that you have in your database so
basically this this a near neighbor rule
right so you will actually have to
compute say a distance between the
receive descriptors so you collect them
and then what you do is that you
basically grab the the minimum and
select or establish that correspondence
following this rule right so essentially
as you're selecting the the most similar
feature based on some appearance
representation so this course are going
to be my random variable of interest
okay I want to predict based on these
data if the correspondence is actually
true or false so this is actually the
statistical model that I came up with
and the main idea is as follows so if I
have a minimum distance for a true
correspondence somehow that that minimum
distance should be an outlier with
respect to the distances of the false
matches okay
so if we have a good representation
which in this case if there's actually a
good one it has to be it has proven to
be a good one then very likely that
score should look like an outlier with
respect to the statistics of the false
matches
okay so overall you can actually think
about that there's a underlying process
with two distributions one distribution
that is essentially drawing
distances for good correspondences and
another distribution that is giving you
samples for false matches okay so when
you collect these distances essentially
when you run your feature matcher and
you collect this set so it is equivalent
or you can think about getting that data
set as drawing from this mixture model
right from these distributions now since
I'm I'm I'm actually considering a 3d
vision problem at most I can have a
correct correspondence right
that's because feature matching aims at
identifying the same 30-point depicted
at two images okay so at most I can have
one good solution so this means that
this said if I'm lucky and I have a
correct correspondence I'm actually
drawing one sample from this green curve
which is representing this case the true
correspondences but then I actually have
a lot of false matching scores right
because you know there are other points
and therefore I'm going to get scores
that are actually coming from with this
red distribution so the goal here is
that somehow what I want to do is model
this course coming from this
distribution because I actually have
more data for it right for example if
you want to fit a parametric model you
know that you need a lot of samples to
actually get a good estimate of the
parameters that you want right but in
this case if I were to fit some model
and try to get some parameters I only
have at most one sample so it's not
going to be that reliable from one
sample or it's in this case from the
fourth matches it's reaching in data
right as I explained before so I can
actually work with this now rather than
actually working with all the or you
have questions this is this is
considered only one feature on one query
say money that I have one query feature
and then I just compare that query with
all the rest so this is only for one
okay okay so rather than actually using
the entire data that I have here to try
to come up or estimate a distribution
parameters of a distribution what I'm
going to do is actually try to focus
on the minimum distance that this
process can actually generate and that's
because they're near the nearest
neighbor matcher it only focuses on the
minimum distance right so the rule
effect is telling it to only decide
based on the minimum distance that you
get out of this sampling so the goal
isn't to model what is the minimum
distance that this process can generate
and for that actually there are
statistical theories that give you the
distribution that models that behavior
so once that once I have that model of
the minimum distance coming from this
read process then I can actually do a
test and check if the minimum distance
that I have agrees with that model that
I just computed if so then I can
actually predict that it is false
otherwise is actually good that's the
whole idea of this oh that's actually a
good a good question so this is just an
illustration and I'm not assuming the
Gaussian or anything like that this is
just to the state that I have two
distributions they may have weird shapes
and so forth this is just to illustrate
that I am considering two processes here
yep
so okay so what I'm gonna use here is
something that is called extreme value
theory and it's a statistical theory
that deals with maximum or minimum of a
random process essentially it aims to
give you the distributions that will
model either the largest scores coming
from a random process or the minimum
scores from a random process and in
particular for this problem the theorem
that that works the best is something
that is called the block maximum Theory
theorem sorry it turns out there in the
limit you can prove that the
distribution that models the minimum or
the maximum is a distribution called the
generalized extreme value distribution
so it is actually a very complex
distribution but it is so general that
in the limit actually holds and
according to the theory calls for a lot
of processes and it has special cases so
one of the special cases that are
using a lot actually the Rayleigh
distribution but all those that are
coming for example are why both record
and grumble okay so just to give you an
example of how these theory works
imagine that I have a normal
distribution in 1d okay and then imagine
this this experiment so I'm gonna draw
10,000 sample from a Gaussian just from
this Gaussian distribution and then you
keep the minimum of that okay then you
draw another 10,000 samples from from
the same distribution and you keep you
keep again the minimum of that so you
repeat that process for that experiment
multiple times
saving your the minimum score that you
got okay
the distribution that is going to model
those minimums it's actually the GeV or
the general extreme value institution
according to this theory so what I'm
showing here is that I actually ran that
experiment I drew these samples and I
fitted the GeV so this will be the GeV
that the distribution modeling only the
minimum samples that these Gaussian
distribution generates okay does that
make sense and just to give you a bit of
an evidence that this actually works
this is a sorry this is assume of this
but it's actually plotting the histogram
of those minimums that I that I stored
when I was running this experiment so so
this is a very general way to tomorrow
minimums and maximums
you can I mean should be easy to see
that maximum can be modeled as well
because you can turn maximum by just
make negating that score right so you
flip it it's like in the optimization
the theoretical limit so are you asking
like if the right distribution is this
one the generalized extreme value
distribution but are you asking about
the bounce like what would be the yes
this is parametric model but there is it
is unbounded I mean this model
here okay but it's actually very
unlikely so what this is saying is that
most of the time when you take the
minimum from a process very likely is
gonna fall in this region it's not
telling you yes yes there's a parametric
form for it yes it's an it's part of an
exponential family so it has scale shape
and location okay so it's actually
parameter yeah yes yes so so this
histogram is the histogram of the
minimum that I kept and then the red
curve that you see is the GV that I feel
yeah so I'm gonna use this model for
modeling the minimum scores of the false
matches okay and and then I'm gonna use
this to check if the minimum that I that
the nearest neighbor matcher is using to
decide agrees with it or not okay so the
actually the algorithm is pretty simple
so what we're going to before I move on
here I forgot another thing in order for
these to work we actually have to grab a
large number of samples right so imagine
that instead of grabbing 10,000 samples
I only grabbed two so the likelihood of
well the domain of where that those
samples will be very lucky is going to
be around six right if you only graph
two samples very likely you will get a
common or what is considered in normal
value but when you gravel a bunch of
them then your chances of getting rare
data from the process increases so this
theory essentially requires a lot of
data to make sure that you have rare
cases so that you can actually fit these
distribution okay okay so back to the
problem so this is the algorithm is
actually very fairly simple so once you
actually compute it all the distances
comparing all these descriptors the idea
is then to only focus on those that are
small right because I'm I'm deciding
based on the minimum distance so in this
case I'm just going to graph K smallest
distance and then the idea is to fit a
extreme valid model based on the film
that I showed earlier but in this case
I'm gonna discard the minimum distance
and that's because if it turned out to
be correct in the model we'll have a
bias in implicit in defeating right and
I don't want that but very likely the
remaining points will come from the
false matching random process right
that's because I have a lot of data from
it so then this estimate is going to be
fairly okay then once I have my
distribution that I call G in this case
by the way I am using capital letters
for CDF's
and what I'm gonna do is use the CDF to
check the the minimum distance or the
agreement with it so my minimum distance
that I kept I'm going to evaluate the
CDF there and then I'm going to have
another threshold that's going to help
me decide so if this value which is some
probability is actually above this
threshold then I can actually predict
that yourself false correspondence
because it's agreeing with yeah yeah but
but you know in practice I mean that's
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah theoretically
speaking you can prove in the limit that
actually don't converge to something
like this what you're talking about is
the location of this distribution yes
yes
so yeah the this sample will affect yeah
the the location of this distribution
yeah for sure but in the limit it
actually is the parametric from the
disguise
- this one yes per query that's exactly
right
so here it's fine because typically when
you detect features you will get like
thousand features or 2,000 features of
course depending on the scene that
you're seeing right if it's well
textured you will have a lot of features
but if it's a wall that with no texture
at all probably you will have a few but
yeah this is run per for every feature
yes okay so this is the algorithm is
fairly simple and so the distribution
the generalized extreme value
distribution has some parameters that
are actually hard to fit and actually
turns out that the maximum likelihood
estimator has some nice properties only
under certain conditions but then if you
don't comply with it then there's no
guarantee of maximum likelihood at all
so in order to avoid any issues with it
so we decided to use a special case of
that which is the Rayleigh distribution
it only has one parameter parameter
which is the scale and that that'll sort
of like minimize those issues that I was
explaining so I'm going to show you some
experiments that I dated some results so
for this experiment I use the data set
that is widely used in in the community
it is called the Oxford define covariant
data sets it's giving you basically a
bunch of images and for every image you
have homography s-- remember the
homography transformation of pixel to
pixel from image to image 1 to image 2
so they give you this ground truth okay
so you can actually get or determine
what are the right correspondences when
you do this experiment
thanks to this home ography so you can
actually run your matching method and
then thanks to the grant to identify
which corresponds to site good so these
are actually ROC plots you know true
positives on the y axis meaning that how
good my predictor worked you know
determining right correspondences on the
x axis we have false positive rate which
meaning the rate of false alarms meaning
that
if the classifier 30 was correct but in
reality was not okay so clearly what we
want is a point that is high in false in
true positive rate and and minimum in
false positive rates okay so in order to
get this curve you you vary the
threshold so from zero to maybe some
high number and that's how for every
threshold that you have you have a point
in this curve okay so I'm actually
evaluating several threshers are the
same thing so these are a couple of
baselines that I'm comparing the
proposed approach the proposed approach
is actually the red curve we named this
matter recognition Rayleigh so on the
Left we have four sift features and on
the right we have four serve features
the main baseline here is what I call
lowest ratio but also in the community
it is known as the seif ratio test that
test is very simple so when you do your
matching you get your distances you
divide the smallest distance and the
second-most smallest distance that ratio
is widely using the community to
actually filter bad correspondences then
I used another baseline just to compare
something that is called the browns
ratio it was paper cvpr
it's very similar to the sift ratio test
but instead of dividing the the smallest
distance with respect to the second one
we take the average of the second one
and the third as the denominator and
then we again compute the ratio so that
is the black curve and then there's
another method that is very similar to
the one proposed but it was proposed
mainly for visual classification and
what they found in a pammi paper is that
the Weibull distribution at least for
those problems worked well in another
domain so here I'm showing that the
Rayleigh distribution for feature
matching actually works well so as you
can see here the red curve is above the
other methods which means that that this
seems to be working okay so on average
you will see in
present of three to five percent okay if
you just want to predict true
correspondences by just using the
similarity score of the six matches okay
so this turned out to be really good and
then the next problem that I wanted to
tackle given this was to speed up all
the estimations that that occur for
example in structure for motion right so
once you have these correspondences you
at the end of the day want to get a 3d
model or maybe estimate a home ography
or fundamental matrix in order to do
other things to understand for example
the relative motion of cameras and so
forth and in order to do that we
actually have to run something that is
called ransack and ransack can be slow
especially if we pass a an image pair
that has only a few correspondences that
are correct say for example 5 percent of
where profit is going to take forever so
just to remind you about ransack ransack
is this iterative algorithm where you
have your candidate correspondences in
our domain but it's actually more
general you select randomly a subset of
the data then based on that subset you
fit a model basically you get a
hypothesis and then the other the next
step is to check with the data itself
and say ok how many points in my data
set I agree with the model that this
hypothesis that I just draw drew ok so
you repeat this and you always keep it's
sort of like a greedy algorithm you
always keep the one that is explaining
the most of your data in you know of the
kind of correspondences and then once
you reach a number of iterations you
return the best model so I wanted to
speed that up and one way to do so is
well ransack originally is randomly
drawing points from your data set using
a uniform distribution so so every point
actually is equal right but given these
previous knowledge of of this predictor
right I can actually get a score or
indicating which correspondents are
likely to be good so this CDF that I was
evaluating with
the minimum distance can be used as an
informative feature right I can actually
normalize that and get a distribution
over the correspondences and get some
sort of an important sampling strategy
to do so so if I if I follow that
sampling strategy then very likely I can
speed things up because very likely I
will hit the correct correspondences and
get the models very quickly so that is
the idea now if we use this course from
the previous algorithm and actually
works well but actually found out
another way to speed this a little bit
more yeah that's what he was saying yeah
depending on the yeah yes yes yeah
[Music]
interior could yes good yeah okay so the
way I did it in my experiments is that I
got a training set offline and I
computed the threshold and then I used
it in a testing side yeah but but yeah
in theory yeah I will have to do I mean
yeah that will be a problem as you
described yeah well luckily in practice
we can actually do this all right so
just to continue I wanted to follow a
different strategy very similar to what
I showed earlier but as gangue actually
was mentioning the algorithm that I
presented it's actually for every
feature right so I had to have to
compute that for every feature
well I can actually grab the entire
information from all the features and
exploit it right so essentially if you
if you have this query features and then
you compare with your reference features
you can actually create this matrix
where you you know arrange the distances
such that for it for this row so if
we're the rows are actually
corresponding to the query features and
then the columns are giving you or
storing the distances that you get when
you compare say for example this query
with all the database or reference
features over there so every column
essentially is a comparison okay so
every row is corresponds to to the query
features now the predictor that I showed
earlier was working only with one row
okay but I can actually exploit all
these data and then probably do
something better in order to gain more
data on write and feed up on another
model so just remember that the random
variable of interest is actually the
minimum distance always so we're going
to be focusing on the minimum distance
of every single row what I want to do
here or the idea is actually to come up
with a mixture model that describes the
statistics of the minimum distance when
they run the entire matter considering
all the information that I have okay I
still have a lot of data coming from the
false correspondences so I should be
able to use everything no problem but
for the true ones probably I won't have
enough it depends on the images so I
cannot use EVT directly so for that I
will have to do something something else
that I'll explain in a second so what I
came up with is again another very
simple approach where I'm gonna assume a
mixture model of this sort and this F is
a CDF modeling all the minimum distance
that I've observed when I match my
features it could be good or bad okay
but a similar to the previous algorithm
I will I'm also considering two
processes one that that is a explaining
the correct distances for for cursory
explaining that this is for for the
correct correspondences and another
for the butt ones so you know that in a
mixture model you need a mixture mixture
parameter right in this case that
mixture per our parameter is called the
in layer ratio that in light ratio
essentially is the probability that if
you select a random one candidate
corresponds what is the probability that
that one will be a good one okay and so
the mixture model is actually fairly
simple so you will have two densities
that are mixed together thanks to this
in Irish so these are actually these
these models the CDF for the fourth
matches again I'm gonna use the GeV
because I have a lot of data and I'm
focusing on minimum so therefore I can
actually use CVT but for the ones that
are actually correct I may not have
enough data and I may not be able to
model it with a GeV so here we actually
had to look into the histograms and we
determined that the gamma distribution
was modeling well the shape so here we
just use gamma and so now the importance
of a correspondence to do this sampling
for ransac can be simply calculated with
a Bayesian approach right so if you do
your basic math you will use the PDF and
you will get a function that if you pass
the minimum distance in question it will
give you a likelihood that that one is
actually going to be a good match or not
so this is what I'm going to be using
for speeding up ransac now the problem
is that now I actually have to recover
all the parameters for each of these
distributions and the Enlai ratio from
the data ok so in order to get those
parameters I propose the following
algorithm so the first step is going to
be using the predictors that I
introduced earlier and separate those
minimum distances that are likely to be
good and likely to be false then for
those that are labeled as good I'm going
to feed a gamma distribution and then
for those that are labeled as false I'm
going to use are going to feed the GeV
distribution and then the last parameter
that I need to estimate is actually the
Enlai ratio for that I propose solving
the following least
problem okay so let me explain how this
works so the V vector is grabbing the
empirical CDF from the minimum sample so
if you grab all the minimum samples for
every row and a matrix that I showed
earlier you can actually call in MATLAB
empirical CDF and I will give you like a
cdf numerical function okay so you can
actually stack that up here and then
what this is saying is that somehow the
Enlai ratio is that the scalar that
allows me to linearly combine these two
to predict this value right so then it
means that this e when you multiply by
this matrix a should be able to get me
or predict this value sort of like a
regression problem here so in order to
construct these matrix a what I'm gonna
do is evaluate the minimums that I got
and evaluate the CDF for the good matcha
for what I believe is using the model
that I just found out or yeah the for
the correct matches and then the model
of the G V for the false correspondence
is evaluated at the distances that I
have then I want to make sure that you
know the sum of these guys which you
which are the scalar so that I can have
my model as stated has to sum up to one
and then this was more like a hack that
allows us to actually get better
estimates and I'll explain that in a
second so this this is basically just
bounce on this solution okay so
obviously this entire ratio has to be
larger than zero but it has to be upper
bounded you know in theory this epsilon
is 0 and 1 between 0 and 1 but then we
found out practically that this tau
which is actually the in lie ratio
estimated from the predictor that I
introduced earlier helped us to actually
force the algorithm or this or the
solver to get with a good optimal with a
good solution sorry here I have a
mistake should be over Epsilon
let me show you some results we
this algorithm so top roam showings for
sift features bottom row for surf so
this red plot here is just showing the
histogram of the minimum distances
coming from the false matches now sorry
from the truth from the true of matches
and then the red curve is the curve that
I found out with the proposed algorithm
then here the blue one is for the false
matches this is the GeV that I found the
journalist extreme value distribution
and then when I solve everything this is
the curve that I got the green curve the
continuous curve and then the histogram
is actually the histogram of the minimum
distance that I have that I of surf
we're just grabbing the minimum distance
from the matrix now this black plot is
the weight that I get by just applying
to be the base formula to get the sort
of like a confidence on correctness and
well as you can see here at least
qualitatively the fit is actually quite
good it's actually not that bad even
though that you know there are a few
hacks to to make it work now this gives
a good general picture that the
algorithm is working but what about the
estimates of the in liar in liar ratio
itself so here I'm showing this table
where I have several image pairs and I
have three columns so the column width
with no squiggle or anything is just a
ground truth so that's the ground truth
epsilon hat is the estimate that I get
by solving the least course I proposed
an epsilon tilde is a modified least
squares except that I don't have this
upper bound with the Tau that I was
mentioning before so the observation
here is that if I actually don't put
that upper bound the solution tends to
overshoot so for example consider this
row so if I don't put the upper bound
and actually the value is super wrong so
it overshoots but if when I put the
upper bound it actually behaves a bit
better so you can see the same trend in
other
image pairs even with different
descriptors so this actually I know it's
actually different it's different from
tasks it's lower than tell yes and yeah
this made it work
better than without the the upper bound
okay so this is just to get the results
of the model okay but then this is not
showing the speed-up that I can achieve
with with a ransack approach so I'm
showing this table on homography
estimation and our approach is called EB
sack which is in shown in this column
we're comparing this with ransack and
other methods that are also accelerating
ransack converges the most famous one is
actually Prozac and I sorted their
results so as you can see here in this
table every row is a different image
pair here is some data so for example
this first row is using surf features
then the second row is safety features
and here is the number of
correspondences that I got and then this
epsilon is a ground truth for that image
pair so this means that only 1% of the
Canada correspondence was correct
according to the ground truth and I saw
them okay so the lowest in my ratio to
the highest in liner ratio so these are
too many numbers but I want you to focus
on this boxes that I'm highlighting so
what you can see here for example
consider the first row models means the
number of hypotheses that the album had
to draw in order to reach to to the good
solution and then time here is just
milliseconds the number of milliseconds
that it took to actually converge so
what you can see here is that actually V
sack thanks to this model
it only took forty four point two
milliseconds to actually reach to a
solution compared to for example Prozac
which is actually faster but the number
of good runs means that out of the 300
trials that I got evey sack 100% of the
time returned the same
which was good the prozac only less than
1% return a good solution then these
remaining
results were completely wrong so this
means that you know if you sack tends to
be more consistent than than others and
of course in this case ransac took
forever never converts and so never
returned a good solution and you you see
the same train as you go down
so you sack is very competitive
especially when the inliner ratio is
very low but when you start getting a
higher in lire ratio meaning that you
have more good correspondences than if
you suck tends to behave on par with the
competing methods okay so the real
advantage here is when you have an image
pair that is not that well behaved in
terms of that we don't have that many
lire in layers okay so now that actually
comprised a part of what I did or what I
as part of my PhD and then I'm going to
talk about some other topics that I
recently that I'm recently working and
these are actually results that I
haven't published yet formally but I
just want to show where I'm going and
what I'm thinking in terms of research
now so I'm gonna show an approach to
learn from a long-tailed data set and
this is work that I did with Devin
remanent from CMU last summer although
we're still working on it and the
motivation came from from this picture
right he's very excited about the open
word problem and then I got excited
about it as well because deals with the
rare data and clearly the problem if you
actually train say a network using these
data set very likely the network is
gonna buy us right it's gonna do very
well for the classes that have a lot of
samples but are going to do poorly for
for these concepts that only have a few
samples so this problem is actually
different from future learning because
here we're actually trying to tackle
both problems at the same time so you
have concepts that have a lot of samples
but others that only have few so how do
you you know make the network world you
know behave well for
both of them at the same time right now
also the community hasn't or doesn't
have a good evaluation protocol so
another contribution that we believe is
is useful is a protocol that we that
we're proposing here some some previous
work that are tackling this are can be
categorized as follows so sampling based
solutions essentially say well if you
have this unbalanced data set well try
to balance it so you can probably
understand some classes and try to come
up with a training set that that has
fairly than the same number of training
instances the meta learning approaches
they're actually very interesting so
what they do in a CNN is that they train
another module that predicts the grading
updates for the classes that have only a
few samples okay and then some other
problems that are actually very related
future learning well these are actually
fairly recent but each of them is very
different and then cost based
essentially is imposing penalties in the
optimization problem right it's gonna
penalize the classifier it's actually
doing a poor job for classes that are
not well represented so what we're
proposing is something very simple we
wanted to come up with something simple
because that's what people you know add
up more easily right so the idea was
yeah yes yes exactly so so yeah this
this picture yeah there's not only every
everything's label except that you have
you know for some more than others so we
proposed this can we learn an embedding
that allows us to deal with this in
unbalanced okay and the idea came up
mainly from the from a Gaussian mixture
model if you think of it every single
concept that you want to learn and it is
represented from a single Gaussian
distribution then you remember that
indicating the Gaussian mixture model
you have these priors that somehow are
encoding them or can encode the the
imbalance in the data set right so the
idea is to
that model to then take that out of the
equation and see if the if the
classifier will do better if we somehow
tweak it to ignore that imbalance so the
idea of this embedding is actually to
represent each concept with a single
centroid and hopefully the network will
learn a transfer yeah function that that
minimizes inter class variation so we
can have a compact representation for
for all the instances per class so here
I'm just giving you an example of how
this works you know so cats are very
popular on the web cars as well but when
you you know search for white reindeer
it's very unlikely that you will find
many pictures so that's the the overall
idea and one of the benefits that we
thought this could have is the following
compared to linear classifiers and you
have your linear classifier and you have
any training instance say for example
false in this in this region there very
likely this new instance is not going to
give you an update of your parameters
because it's already classified
correctly but when you add another
instance using this center based
approach they're very likely that Center
has to move okay
so it's actually very sensitive to that
and we we think that this is actually a
benefit of our approach so in order to
learn this embedding we propose this
optimization function so classical cross
entropy loss where we have the
embeddings and though we are the
parameters of the network and then we
have the center's one Center per class
and then if you only consider this part
of the of the equation essentially is
just encoding the nearest class mean
classifier which is very similar to the
nearest neighbor it's just going to
assign the class to the closest mean and
then we added a regular icer here just
to make sure that these centers which
are actually optimized or learn using
you know regular deep learning methods
just so that it complies with the
statistics of the embedding as you run
your optimization process
so here this term is just grabbing from
the minibars computing the center from
the mini batch and then enforcing that
the estimates are close to two to the
center that is being estimated from the
deep learning framework so this is this
is the objective function that we
propose as you will as you see it's
actually it has some relationship with
linear classifier which makes it easy to
implement and the relationship is the
following if you expand this quadratic
term you will get this and then
essentially you directly establish the
relationship with regular softmax
classifiers with the exception though is
with this bias over here this bias is
actually constrained by these terms so
the bias actually half of the center of
the class that you have in hand this
term actually can be factored out and
then cancels out so the relationship
with with linear classifier is that
essentially we're fitting linear
classifiers where the W is represents
the center and then the by actually
restricted by the norm of the center or
the yes the norm of the center this is
useful in for implementation details now
in terms of the evaluation protocol what
we propose is the following approach so
we have the imbalance data set and what
we want is actually to capture and see
if the classifier generalizes well for
classes that are not well represented so
what we propose is to actually sample
the training set multiple times and then
for every sample train a different model
okay now now that I have those models
I'm gonna use the balanced set in order
to make sure that the classifier is
actually generalizing given this
different samples right this is just to
measure and see if if if I have a class
variation for some concepts can this
generalize and then very normally you
just plot of report the per class
accuracy average so out of those trials
that you had report just the average for
those trials for every
laughs right that's we'll be proposing
comparison with other methods which is
just train and then evaluate using as if
you had a balanced data set which may
not be right
so here are some results on on small
scale data sets I compared this with
other center based approaches wonder was
recently published at cvpr 2016 no 717
was I Karl essentially I Karl grabs a
softmax computes all the features for
all the classes that you have and then
computes the Center for every class and
that's it so there are two versions one
that is unnormalized which is what I
just described and then normalized means
that all the vectors that you are
dealing with they have to be normalized
and the reason that they used it
according to them is that actually that
actually helps reduce some noise effects
in the data then I just use the regular
GMM approach you know after I have the
softmax representation I feel a GMM and
that's it those are the baseline so on
the right you will see the accuracy the
average of the softmax classifier and as
you can see here for example for M list
you know that M is actually a balanced
data set I actually had two longtail
them to make their imbalance so as the
index grows the imbalance growth here in
in the plot so as you can see here the
the average or the accuracy drops when
that imbalance of course this shaded
region is just the standard deviation
that I got from the trials now the plot
on the left is just showing the relative
performance that means the performance
the accuracy that I got from every of
these methods divided by the accuracy
that I got from the software classifier
this is just to clearly see if there's
an improvement or not clearly that's an
improvement you get something larger
than one if there's a drop you know you
will see points below this line so in
the end this case most of them actually
behave okay and that's because these
data set is is I mean it's not that
complex but once you actually analyze
other data sets
five four ten you will see that actually
the center based approaches especially
improve the accuracy on those classes
that are in balance okay well you can
see that actually the problem is hard so
softmax tends to bias a lot for classes
in the head meaning those that are very
well represented but it does very poorly
with with classes that are not very well
represented now when we increase the
scale of the datasets it's a little bit
harder to to note the improvement here
though but there is some improvement so
here if you look closely the black dots
are actually above the line which means
that we're actually observing an
improvement thanks to the centre based
approach and same here with another data
set that is called tiny imagenet so this
is a proposed approach and you will see
some dots that are above the line so
which means that this approach is
somewhat helping I mean just to clearly
emphasize what's going on here I
summarize the relative performance for
classes in the head and classes in
detail for different methods here I
didn't consider the Gaussian mixture
model cuz actually as you saw it's not
performing well and for for all the data
sets that I consider so for the head the
proposed approach is actually showing
some dropping performance but it's
actually not that much so it's very
close to soft max but when you look at
the classes in the tail you can see that
that that number is actually larger than
one which which means that there's on
average some improvement in in terms of
classification all right so this is one
of the current projects that I'm still
working on and then I also want to talk
about another project that is
visualizing a few things from cnn's that
are used for pixel level tasks this is
also work done with Tunica in a human
cell and ever remanent and let me give
you the motivation of why I wanted to do
this so we humans actually can learn
very easily from even a single example
right but we also have the ability to
say eh that object I've never seen
before right so we have that ability of
discovering new things and then learn
new things by just experiencing the
world that's something that I would like
to enabling in computing so some idea
that I got was well maybe I can actually
discover that new knowledge assuming
that that new knowledge somehow looks
like an outlier of the known they're
already known knowledge okay and I
already have theory as I showed earlier
using this the feature matching problem
and but the problem there is that the
theory that I showed earlier was using
the nearest neighbor classifier and then
CNN's are somewhat different
right so somehow I have to establish
this link of the new the nearest
neighbor classifier in CNN's so that's
what motivated to study this this
problem here and so we introduced
something that is called the
compositional nearest neighbors approach
to visualize what's going on here so I
assume everybody's familiar with pics
toothpicks and maybe results of segments
so on the first row I'm showing labeled
two images where the idea that you pass
the labels of a facade in this case and
then the CNN will generate an image that
you know agrees with this input the
compositional nearest neighbor is
actually something that is very simple
so if you grab the you're trained CNN
and then you grab the last layer of your
convolutional neural net and then you
graph a specific patch corresponding to
one pixel
and use that as a feature descriptor
then you can actually search for the
nearest training patches in your
training set and then create this image
that looks a lot like what the CNN is
actually generating even though it's
noisy that may be because of the
parameters that we used but somehow we
were able to replicate the results of
the CNN so this is using pics to pigs
this is using another CNN which is
segment and as you can see here if you
just compare these two they over all
tend to have similar behavior even
though there are some artifacts there
now this column it is classical nearest
neighbor where you will
percent entire image using some
bottleneck feature of your architecture
and then just retrieve the most similar
image from your training set so just to
be clear say that I want to synthesize
the value of this pixel what I will do
is grab a patch from the last layer of
the CNN you said as a feature descriptor
and then searching my training set so in
this case I'm visualizing that I found
that maybe this is a window that looks
like this and then what the
compositional near neighbor is doing is
just grabbing the information from the
training pair raveling the RGB value
here and copy near here okay what is
nice about this approach is that this
allows us to get correspondence meaning
that I know why this value is maybe
Brown and that is because it's coming
from this training set that you know
it's very similar to two in appearance
at least yeah not not at this time
but that's one of the steps that we're
considering so right now it was sort of
like a proof of concept of seeing if
this is actually working or not and
somebody's actually replicating the
results for example something that
caught our attention was why is it that
the CNN is is drawing this red I don't
know what that is but this red region
well we found out that is actually
coming from from this image that has
that so somehow it's actually
replicating that and so we came to the
conclusion that maybe it's memorizing
the training set somehow and then it
does some sort of a fast
nearest-neighbor
synthesis which is similar to what we're
proposing here these are more results on
the same idea the assets are facade
cityscape and can--but so these are
results for pigs to pigs these are for
segments and so as you can see here
picks the pigs and the compositional
nearest neighbors they actually tend to
look very similar to each other okay
same same here for segments and so it
looks like yeah it looks like the
networks are memorizing somehow the data
set and then replicating that that
information and some interesting feature
as well is that that patch that we're
using us as a pixel representation
we know for sure that actually codes
sort of global information but also
local information by global information
I mean for example the color of the
facade and for the local information for
what kind of window style are we
rendering so somehow the network's able
to figure that out and embed that
information there more results on other
data sets from labels to images and then
from images to Google Maps like images
so as you can see here we replicate a
very very similar result now another
interesting observation that we saw here
is that what if instead of you know
rendering the expected output given by
the pairs right because his image
translation can we reconstruct the input
image using the same approach and it
actually turned out to be good as well
so if we use the same representation but
reconstruct the input from the training
set we we can actually do so so for
example consider this row over here we
were able to input this image which has
never seen before by the the CNN and
then by doing this composition of
nearest neighbors we can actually
reconstruct it it actually resembles the
scene very well so this is something
that that got our attention and it looks
like they're basically their
presentation is so good that that is
even encoding things from the input that
that is allowing us basically to just
fine
during the information from the training
set and then just copy and pasting the
the information as the final output so
this happens also with with other type
of data like labels
yeah yeah nothing nothing like that you
yeah that's definitely saying here
before that somehow the network learns
that so it contains these global
information exactly of what color where
of the facade we're rendering
what kind of style of facade but when we
in but also local information the
windows information for example what
kind of window is it is there a glass
there so these are intriguing results
that we're still are still we are still
working on this but yeah now the last
experiment if you're familiar with pics
the pics they are using a unit
architecture and it has this bottleneck
and then you have a lot of the Curie
decoding layers so it looks like that
the network is actually using the
bottleneck to retrieve similar images
and probably use the most similar one as
the basis and then as you progress over
the deconvolution of layers somewhat is
morphing the output by adding more
details and details and details until
you reach to a final output so for
example this peak that you observe here
which is the output of the convolutional
layer it can be explained that it it
came from the most similar image okay so
it looks like the the the CNN is just
morphing you know for every
deconvolution that you're actually doing
until you reach the final output so I'm
still we're still working on this we
have more experiments in one of the next
steps when you do the forward pass and
you will get the activation of the
bottleneck and use that as a whole
descriptor of the internals yes exactly
it looks like it's grabbing the most
similar image patches
exactly exactly yes yes that's exactly
right alright so that is actually pretty
much it so just to give you some
conclusions of what I presented today
so I hope I convinced you that extreme
value theory is actually fairly or it's
a good theory to model rare data I
showed that with feature matching it
allows us to predict good
correspondences and also speed up rancic
estimation in terms of long tail
datasets
it looks like center based approaches
are I mean it's giving some insight that
that that we may be up to something
there but we still need to work on that
more and then this visualization
framework to understand to understand
pixel level tasks from cnn's are still
intriguing right and so now with all
these unseen inputs to the network we
can explain how it will behave at least
using this framework that I introduced
alright so that actually concludes my
talk if you if you are more interested
about some other projects that I have in
AR or structure from motion feel free to
stop by my website be Fragoso calm and
yeah that's pretty much it thank you
[Applause]
yeah yeah so yeah we haven't tried them
I don't know I will be able to answer
that but I assume that it'll do the best
to actually replicate the results based
on this yes yes
it looks like it's I'm not sure I you
know take it with a grain of salt I'm
not sure I'm not sure what will happen
that's what I'm saying we're still
working on this I don't want to give a
bad answer
but yeah it's it's very interesting I
believe
thank you